Allora camicetta rosa cipria mai
indossata indossata una volta non lo sa
nessuno taglia S €10 Anzi no Mettiamola
cque Ciao bellissima camicetta posso
vederla indossata certo Eccola qui la
prendi Ma è una s che veste s o Veste
più grande no perché voglio essere
sicura che mi stia Io vesto s e come hai
visto dalla foto mi sta perfetta OC
Riesci solo a prendermi le misure da
spalla a spalla dall'ascella alla Manica
e dalla spalla alla
manica Ecco le misure che mi avevi
richiesto Ok grazie mille la prendo Ci
mancherebbe altro dop tutto sto casino
mi ha fatto fare Ciao Scusa c' ho
pensato bene Non voglio più prenderla e
fammela vedere indossata e misura come
una S o non come una S Prendimi la
misura dalla spalla al colletto dal
colletto alla spalla e da tutte e due le
spalle poi non me la prendi carolinda
Marsiglia vuole acquistare la tua
camicetta carolinda Marsiglia mi hai
svoltato la giornata allora vediamo qual
è l'imp Point più vicino a me per
spedire il pacco Eccolo perfetto
Caroline la tua camicetta sta per essere
spedita pacco spedito Adesso vediamo se
trovo un vestito per la festa di Chiara
Eccolo è lui